hello everyone thank you so much for
coming out tonight to see
quippies the stranger on the big screen
my name is perry nemruff i'm with
collider and i'm absolutely thrilled to
be here tonight to get to moderate this
post screening q a for you
let's meet the team behind the stranger
we have writer director
vinasude and stars micah monroe
avin jogia and dane dehaan
hello hello everyone i hope you are
doing well huge congratulations
on the project so vina let's kick it off
with you
first and just discussing the genesis of
the idea
what was the starting point and also
what would you say is
the toughest story beat to crack the
genesis
of the stranger was the long simmering
rage that i
felt and i think probably almost every
woman in america felt post 2016
election and i wanted to take that rage
and have
it be personified in a way that was not
uh polite or constructive or necessarily
educational i just wanted it to be
and you guys have seen the end fully
[ __ ] unleashed
so that's where it came from
well micah i'll jump to you this is a
lot because
you shoot at night the entire time and
also you're in almost every single
frame of this series so what would you
say was the most intimidating part of
the process when you first signed on and
how did vina and the crew help
see you through it i think maybe one of
the most intimidating but also
most exciting uh episodes
was when um we tried we pretty much did
almost a one uh for an episode and i
remember reena
coming to me and you know telling me for
the first time you know we're gonna try
and
do this um and it's definitely scary
because you know you got
every part of this take has to be
perfect
and you're you're having to time it with
the camera but also like
in this insanely intense um
scenes and and so it was um
definitely i i was nervous about it but
also really excited because i'd never
done anything like it
and um there was almost something like
uh
maybe similar to a play where you had to
have everything kind of
mapped out and practiced over and over
again um
so yeah that was really fun i do want to
touch on the
technology conversation here and i'm
just curious after going through this
whole process
did this story make any of you rethink
how you
incorporate technology and social media
in your lives today
i mean like in a way we're sort of all
aware of the contract that we've
sort of signed when it comes to like
living our
lives online you know uh it's sort of
like a convenience
and uh connects human connectivity in
exchange for privacy
you know and uh and autonomy so
um yeah i mean it is a bit of a it's a
bit of a spooky sort of
construct the idea that you like your
entire like a ghost
versions of you like there's a weird
myspace
14 year old version of myself echo
living out there
i don't know if it's maybe rethink this
because i think we're so
we're so deep into the the negotiations
that there's no pulling out of the
contract
but yeah it definitely is something to
give you something to think about if
there's anything to be learned from it
on like a personal level it's that
social media is
very much the responsibility of the user
and it can be used for good or confused
for evil it can be used for
fun you know or it can be used to do
really
bad misleading things so i think it's
as people that use social media it's
truly the responsibility of the user not
only to
um you know take responsibility for the
content that they put out but also
fact check and uh be aware of the
content that they're consuming
so vina everyone tonight
got the opportunity to watch the
stranger on the big screen
but was it on your mind much at all that
you were kind of telling a story that
taps into technophobia at all and it was
being designed
to be watched on your phone
yeah i mean that was the meta of it all
you know that was the meta
and the meta meta um that you know the
character
is driven into a night of complete
terror because
dane can track her anywhere she goes a
conceit at one point and we did not do
it because we didn't have the technology
at the release date to do this
but there would be a point where you
know that the creepy kind of ringtone
that you guys heard tonight from dane's
phone that you know repeats itself over
and over and over
we were going to drop each episode on
consecutive
days starting at 7 p.m 8 p.m
9 p.m and every time that an episode
dropped into your phone you would hear a
creepy ring tone
so mid-season at 2 am you're asleep and
ding ding here comes dane's ringtone
i was very curious would people wake up
would they watch the episode it's
mid-season big cliffhanger
would they go to sleep would they dream
about it um so yeah there was a lot and
there will be so much more to discover
in the quimby format in terms of this is
a radically new way
to watch story and to you know
interact with story so dane the last
time we spoke you told me that this was
the first bad guy you've played
since your world view changed and you
know it made me wonder do you think that
was
key to you being able to pull this role
off as well as you did could you have
played
carl before that happened i just think
it would have been a different version
of
carl you know or um definitely
like you said like this was the first
time i've played a bad guy since i've
come to the realization that there
really are people out there that are
just bad
people you know i think when i was
younger i played a lot of bad guys but
with the
the thought that in our hearts
everyone's good and everyone's doing
something for
a reason that they think is good but
certainly
um i've come to realize in the past
three years or so that there's people
out there that are just really
terrible evil bad people that aren't
afraid to do bad things for bad reasons
and i think
um carly very much fits into that world
how about his obsession with the
algorithm
in particular it's just like that kind
of predictive
method it's just all over the place in
our world right now but was there any
specific
example of the use of an algorithm that
you think
really kind of aligned with carl's
agenda while you were
researching for the role well i think
that the ones that were the
closest to what carl is doing were
actually ones that predict health
venus sent me a bunch of uh like ted
talks or podcasts or something about
um you know algorithms that exist now
that are can fairly accurately predict
a person's health uh
and their future of their health and
even like could predict
how you're going to die which is a
really crazy um
thought you know and i think thought is
if you can predict someone's health that
accurately why can't you predict
someone's behavior so that was a really
good launching off point for the why of
what
carl's doing and made it all make a lot
of sense you know certainly
i think you know it would be possible to
go back into a person's myspace facebook
collect all this data see what they're
doing try to decipher
fact from fiction and from that you
probably could make an algorithm that's
fairly
um accurately predictive of their future
behavior you know
i mean i see it now even with like on
instagram and the
ads on instagram and it's like so
accurately exactly when i
want to buy um it's crazy you know and
they get me sometimes
um you know they they know exactly what
i want in that moment and it's on my
instagram as an ad
dana and i talked about um an ai
developer her name is jane
uh jen goldbeck and she was part she
wrote a lot about cambridge analytica
and she did a study where she looked at
people's
facebook posts people who had newly
become sober
and they could predict with i think it
was like 85
probability based off your friend
network your posts
who would stay sober and who would
relapse with 85 percent predictability
so you know the algorithms are out there
and yeah who needs
an algorithm who needs god when you've
got an algorithm
oh my god looking at it that way evan
what was it like shooting the scene
where
jj leaves claire because most of
the series he's the guy who actually
believes her and
that was a really tough scene for me to
watch and
digest so was it that challenging for
you on set
actually performing it i think that what
i love about
uh jj's relationship uh with micah's
characters is that there's this sort of
um you know in a world that is sort of
um i don't know how vivina sees it but
this is definitely how i i
interpreted it in a world that is like
sort of like
not believing women distancing
themselves from
from women and or just like the maybe
this cons
contrary on not believing women there's
somebody who does
you know and he sort of represents this
sort of modern
man uh this sort of new slot
of of of male 1 individual who who who
can sort of like be there
to to help and support and is and so i
think that's an interesting character
for uh
a character trait for someone to have to
more to micah's point
like shooting like late nights
sort of make it all this sort of heady
fever dream
it's its own sort of like uh world
that you're acting in and it allows you
can actually stretch and pull things out
that you won't expect it's a vulnerable
state to be shooting
emotional scenes at 4 30 in the morning
after
been doing it for a week and a half so
or even just like you know
two weeks three weeks so so yeah so it's
i always see it it has its disadvantages
as far as like your actual
you know like sleeping health but as far
as like what uh the
sort of in this particular genre of
like sleepless night running around the
city it just adds to that
i'm so excited we finally get to talk
about the ending
particularly carl's demise why go with
the wolves what inspired that decision
dorothy had to have her dog she had to
have toto it's a story about
um a girl and her dog kind of against
the world
and so pebbles you know in many ways you
know
was i mean claire was definitely the
hero but she had a very good
lieutenant in in pebbles um i
have been fascinated by the fact that we
live in an urban oasis that has
a million tons of wildlife running
around coyotes i have bears in my
neighborhood
we live in a place that you know the
wildness can come in
at any moment and does on the highway
all the time and so i really wanted to
incorporate that facet of
la into the final dynamo between
those two you're always going to win me
over with a story where
like one you let the dog live but then
you also make it kind of like a psychic
hero
micah at the very end where do you think
claire's
head is at because i read it and she's
going back out into the world with kind
of a new sense of strength
but does she i guess does she ever want
to touch a piece of technology again
after all this
good question um yeah i mean i think uh
what i loved about this script is just
seeing this
um huge transition in
this woman like how she
um learns what she's capable of
and i think seeing her walk away
at the end it's a completely different
person than we met
in the beginning and i think that it's
really empowering
and just like um i had so much fun
filming that scene and it was great
because uh
we shot it at the end it was our last
week of shooting and we switched from
uh night shoots back today and
um it was just a great way to to
and end the shoot and now that everyone
here has seen the stranger
straight through is there anything like
an easter egg or a tiny detail that you
really hope people look out for
on a second viewing and don't miss any
fun little things to to kind of search
the frame for
there is one episode like micah pointed
out that is the the one shot episode
that was such a challenge
so fun um and and thankfully i had an
actress like micah who can just
hold every micro moment over the course
of
10 minutes straight um and and and and a
perfect balance
um there are cuts inside that episode
there are three cuts so good luck to an
audience finding them
cool now we know what i'm going to be
doing after this
we have the pleasure of talking with all
of you tonight
but there were so many people involved
in making the stranger
so if each of you had to name an unsung
hero
of the cast and crew who would you why
um i'd say the makeup artist marina
she was a freaking rock star not only
was she amazing with all like
the just the natural makeup but the gore
and the the blood um but she just had
such
a great attitude on set yeah she was
awesome we played the
yeah hard knights but she was great i'm
really bad with directions and i would
get lost almost every day on my way to
set
and i would call freddy and i would say
freddy
i'm lost can you please get me to base
camp and he would always
get me there in a decent amount of time
so
definitely for me it was freddy yeah uh
apollo
ye our cinematographer being able to use
this new
uh uh you know forum or medium and i
he just also had time to talk to me
about what he was doing which is always
i
you know i'm always trying to soak up as
much information as possible so that was
great
paul absolutely superhero of the movie
and
uh and my production designer jenny
mahler she me and paul like were a unit
a trio of trinity
you know in prep trying to think how the
hell are we going to shoot this thing
and make it satisfying you know on a
tiny phone vertically and horizontally
so
it took a lot of minds and our amazing
first aid
i mean my god she's a rock she's like
she was awesome she's so good and so
uh she took care of us so that was
lovely yeah
wow it all it all came together you guys
crushed it a huge thank you to all of
you for spending some time with us
thank you to everybody out there for
joining us for this
screening in conversation tonight tell
everybody you know
about the stranger on quibby and keep
staying safe everyone